こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
ガチャガチャやってますでしょうかなんか
最近ブームじゃない
ブームかわかんないんですけどもなんか
色んな所でガチャガチャコーナーとか
ガチャガチャ専用のお店とかものすごい量
のガチャガチャが並んでるところ結構よく
見るんですよガチャガチャブーム
来てます来てますということで今ですね僕
ここ静岡の静岡鑑定団っていうもう56年
前ぐらいから通い詰めてる何でも売ってる
お店カードとかゲームとかフィギュアとか
漫画とか
駄菓子とか色々売ってるお店があるんです
けれども最近後輩と軽い気持ちでお店来た
んですけども帰り道に気づいたんですよ
めっちゃ改造してるなってでこのこれが
新しいエリアなんですけれどもなんとこれ
静岡の地にもガチャガチャの波が来てます
ガチャガチャコーなってきてるんですよ多
すぎて俺初めて見たのこの量の
ガチャガチャでなんか驚いちゃってあの
Twitterあ間違えたXでXで
ツイートあ間違えたポストしたんですけど
Xでポストしたら色んな人にねもうそれは
あの回してほしいと全部回して欲しい
みたいなコメントがもうたくさん来ました
いや数多いよよく言えたな結構引くこと
ガチャガチャの量多いんですよ俺も未経験
の物量なのでちょっと1回中入って見て
みようと思います
[音楽]
失礼します
すっごいこれすごいよこんなたくさん見た
ことある静岡でないんじゃない静岡じゃ
こんな
ちょっとね結構
驚きの量なんですよこれすごいよ
量がどうやってこんなに仕入れたんだろう
俺は見たことないですねどうなんだろう
東京とかだったらあるんかなあるんかな
それでもここすごいよねこの
[音楽]
わかる
奥行き無限じゃんもうこれこのお店
ガチャガチャ無限にありますこの無限の量
は是非とも全部やろうかと思います何個
ぐらいあるんかな数えてみます数えて
みようか
12345689101156565
[音楽]
×3=195
これだけじゃないんですよこのわかるこの
塊ここのちょっとこれも足して行こうか
[音楽]
全部
合計したところ
315台あります
全部やります
無限にあるって聞いてたので若干多いん
ですけどもちょっと一応
準備はしてきました若干とはさすがに何と
かいけるんじゃないかなと思いまして
そもそもこの無限ガチャガチャとかかるの
か100円でできるガサガサなんでもう
最近少ないよ見てだってこれ
呪術回線の
やつとか500円だからね
ちょっとだけ了解しておきましたどう
でしょう足りるかなこんだけあればまあ
逃げ切れる説はあるぞ
俺普通に持ってるけどもやばいね腕が
10kgありますね早速回していきたいと
思います
今のワンピースのおかずはいないのか知ら
ん星とかは可愛いから俺
わかるのよ
じゃあまずバンビの実から行きたいと思い
ます500円
1,23
45いくぜ
出てきました中身は最後にまとめて開け
ますでもやっぱワンピース人気なんだね
手前になるってことはさまず目に止まる
場所じゃんきっと人気なんだろうなこれ
行きます何これ
ニコロビン達のモチーフフィギュアって
卓上アイドルモチーフフィギュアじゃダメ
なんか400円いきます
はいあ可愛いワンピースたまごっちの
コラボマスコットです300円が優しく
感じるぜ
昔100円から高くて200円300円で
クオリティが日々上がってるんだろうな
ドンザラパイセットだってワンピースの
もうギアフィフスになってるな300円
はいファミリーカプセルラバーマスコット
俺は絶対姉を出します
[音楽]
カプセル
ウォータードームかわいいね僕はアンジェ
出します
はい僕のヒーローアカデミアコレクション
第2弾絶対当てます
[音楽]
僕のヒーローアカデミア
プチバース
ケーキみたいなやつですね400円です
僕のヒーローアカデミア
文化祭のキーホルダー300円
待って待ってやばいラインナップルおじい
さんばっかり
暑いんですかこれはねさすがに渋い
おじさんお願いしますドラゴンボール
スーパーの
ウィンドウアートコレクション
ドラゴンボールのフィギュア
のラバーマスコットさんがいいです
なんか形すごいな
楕円形
ぬいぐるみフィギュア
可愛いまきまさんが欲しいです
アクリルスタンドこれも牧場さんがいい
です
なんか
違和感と思ったら
絶対そばに
全員の背中に乗ってるよ
ハンターハンターのビッグサイズ
フィギュアついに500円来た
500円で
ハンターハンター
欲しいすごい押しのこのやつがある
めっちゃ可愛いこれはもうあいちゃんのA
を出したいですねはいこのブロックだけ
終わりました普通のガチャガチャコーナー
はこのブロックなのよこれでも多いのよ
多分ここでもうね1万円100円でも
100万円以上使ってる気がします
どんどん回していきましょう
でローゼンメイデンじゃん
五等分の花嫁
500円のカブトムシのやつ売り切れてる
んだえーめっちゃ欲しかった虫のやつ
くそ
もうすぐ終わりですマジで手が手首が完全
に折れた
はいこの長い
異常に長いところ終わりました
めちゃくちゃ長いゾン終わったところ
になりました
やって
めちゃくちゃ多いんですけどもまだかなり
ガチャガチャありますこんなもんじゃ
終わらないよまだ100円玉子まだ結構
ずっしりあるのでワンちゃんこれ回し切れ
ますね最終的に苗になるから楽しみです
続きましていきましょう
すごいここら辺のガシャポンあれですね
カプセル型じゃなくてこういう紙とか
クリアボードとかそういうタイプもあり
ますねすごい
ラスト
[音楽]
企画になりました見てください残りの金額
計算通りマジで完璧な計算にちょうどいい
んじゃないこれでも最後回していきたいと
思います
[音楽]
か
いやなんか
高いなってないおいなんだこれは
プレミアムガシャポンっていうハイ
クオリティガシャですねもうね
ガチャガチャもねもう次元が違うんです
最近1回1500円とかあるんですけど
これ多分すごいよね
めっちゃくちゃリアルなんだろうなこの
虹色クワガタとか見て
殿様バッタも1000円とかでしょここの
5000円やばい最後のゾーンやばいぞ
これ要求されるのがもう100円
なんだけど
[音楽]
逆量買いしてもらおうかなどうもという
わけで両替してきました100円
玉500円玉に変換してもらったら
5枚になっちゃいました500円
玉2個入れるガチャなかなかないと
[音楽]
かっこいいよねカプセルもちょっとかっこ
いいな
[音楽]
これが最高金額かな1500円の
カプセルからもうこれは1500円だわ
すごい本当だ
[音楽]
お金崩してきます両替してきましたこれで
多分足りると思います100万円は余裕で
必要なかったですねただ結構エグい金額
言ってる気がするんだけど
てんとう虫のフィギュア
実物の方が安い
[笑い]
やつも800円
ここでけえ絶対落ちたスパイファミリー
これもさこれも出てきた瞬間わかりそうだ
ねアーニャ
ー
ラストです
[音楽]
これで終わりだ
終わりました
1時間半ぐらい回し続けてたよね
お店の中で全部開けるわけにいかないので
お家に帰りたいと思います
お
[音楽]
祭りの屋台の水容量みたいはいというわけ
で全部買ってきましたもうすごい
量だねこれは金額はまだ知らないんです
けれどもとりあえず何が当たったかも
途中から俺はもうほぼ無意識に回してても
自分が何の商品何のガサガサを回してるの
かわかんなくて自分何やってんだろう
みたいな感じでやってたのでとりあえず
全部開封してみたいと思います何が入っ
てるとか1回見ようはいでは早速1個ずつ
見ていきましょう
これガシャポン本体が商品のやつもあり
ますね
これはミッキーマウスカップキャラ
ドナルドダック
あーめっちゃ
可愛いじゃんこうするとこういう帽子を壁
だドナルドダックになるっていう
最高300個行くのでマジでどんどんいき
ますよ次はこれこれももう形がすごいです
ねほぼ完成形なんだこれ
何の説明もないんですけどめっちゃお菓子
っぽいですねあ開いたおおこれは可愛いね
見てクリームに
チェリーが乗ってる指輪ついてるこれ
可愛い指太くて入らんはいこれはさ
にゃんこ大戦争だすぐ分かった
斧入ったこういう感じで背中につけられ
ますいいねそろそろ普通のガシャポンも
行きましょうかこれ開けてみますはいはい
まじでどうコメントしたらいいかわから
ないな次コナンのヘアピンコレクション
マジで最近の人わからん灰原ハムスターと
フルーツタルトあら可愛いハムスターとか
ラットがケーキに乗ってるフィギュアです
ね繋げて遊ぶんでしょうね食品衛生上
大丈夫でしょうかはい何これあちらのお客
様からです
バーのカクテルみたいなやつですねフル
ーツが隣のお客様からですってこうやって
あのバーテンダーから渡されるみたいだね
はい女神のカフェテラスフォールメン
アクリルキーチェーン小野白菊ちゃん
かわいいね次はいはい何これお野菜妖精
さんキャベツに入ってるカエルみたいなの
がいます
可愛いはい
ガシャポンシッシュボードソール02これ
戦隊物のやつキング王者だ
キングオージャーのゴッドアンド出ました
マジでわからんはいかっこいいエビフライ
猫ちゃんはい松屋なんかクオリティ結構
高いな
美味しそうはい
猫みたいなウミウシその名の通り猫みたい
なウミウシ出てきましたこれ素敵ですねん
こんなのやったっけごぼ天が入ってました
ね
何これ
筋肉マンの仲間です塗装してくださいはい
プリキュアっぽいなプリキュアのなんか
キラキラキラのやつですねこれすげー
可愛い消化器の赤いランプみたいな色に
なりましたはいドクターストーンの朝霧幻
渋いとこ出たなスイカとか出て欲しかった
ね次ほいなんかでかいぞなんだ
[音楽]
金属のボードが入ってました食品サンプル
だこれあんかけスパゲティの食品サンプル
ですねミニチュア食品サンプルとか
ちょっと可愛いと思いますよねなにこれ
折りたたみ式のミニキャリーカートマジだ
これ多分これであとタイヤつけて完成なん
ですけどもめんどくさいのでやめときます
[音楽]
可愛らしいアクリルキーホルダー何これ
何これストリートファイターの
チューンリーとリュウが戦ってるなんか
アクリルスタンドでこれはストリート
ファイター好きな人からちょっとたまん
ないんでしょうね知らんけどほいうん
赤べこ入ってましたもうすごいな何でも
入ってんだね今のガチャガチャってはい
何これ
自立しないはいバイキンマン入ってました
すごいスプラトゥーンのイカしたエアー
マスコット
あすごいこんな大きくなった次行きます
何これ
毎日骨太の牛乳ですねクオリティ高すぎ
でしょ
めっちゃ細かいところまで
完全に牛乳パックだハリネズミだ
可愛いラピスラズリハリネズミキラキラし
てて可愛いですねちょっと好きです個人的
にポイントてくださいほぼ
チェーンソーマンのパワーちゃんの
ぬいぐるみ仕様のやつこれ可愛い茶色いの
行きます
ガチャポンクエストはてと剣が2本入って
ましたガチャガチャを集めると
勇者が完成するみたいな主人公ゲットして
武器とかをゲットして
合体させたら
完成するよっていうやつですね刀と立って
だけ出ちゃったんだ
くそ次行きます何だドンジャラのパイワン
ピースかなワンピースのドンジャラのパイ
何か可愛い進撃の巨人のエレンイェーガー
が
ケーキに入ってます次パンパンええ可愛い
明太子ケーキ
すげえ車のナンバープレートそれも
富士山ナンバー好きな番号が貼れるんです
ねすごい
呪術廻戦おお先輩何これなんか昔からこう
いうのあった気がするミニスケジュール帳
これマジで多分かけるんだろうなうわー
細けえカバーもついてんのよゲイが細かい
なんか昔からこういうのあった気がする
けどめっちゃ好きなんですよこういうの次
ウルトラマンブルーザーなんかストーン
ですねウルトラマン
これもよく美味しそうに作るなヒレ
とんかつですすごいね最近のガチャガチャ
まじで食品サンプルだよまだ可愛いはま
ちゃん何これでかすげえうわ開くんだえ
電子レンジですね家作れそうだなもう
ミニチュアで
押しのこアクアです
今度回そうもう結構ガシャポンあげてると
思うんですけれども全然まだあるのが
かなりすいません雑にペース上げていき
ますおっモスバーガーライン型のやつ開け
ます
すごいでかいけどすごいでかいけどパック
だーサンリオのエコバッグですねかわいい
これ
クッキーみたいなまだ可愛いお犬さんの
ドーナツ中に入れるんだろうなこうやって
美味しそうでかいの行きます
めっちゃ作んなきゃいけないけどすごい
リアルですすごくないこれマジで本当に
ガシャポンなのこれ
[音楽]
めっちゃかっこいいけどなこんなレベル
上がってるんだ今ガチャガチャかインフレ
してるなこれほいかわいい猫とスイカなん
と鏡になってます便利そうシナモンロール
の犬どういうこと多分だけどポケモンの
釣りするやつですね
省略します釣りしてる場合じゃないえ
おいしそうリコちゃんのパンセットすごい
なこれハワイのお土産ミニチュア
コレクションだお土産ですおにぎりこれは
中に具が入ってるやつね筋子でした変な鳥
何これ
ハンバーガーセットですゲームセンターに
ありそうなやつキラキラをおめちゃんどう
いうこともうわからんクラゲ使うのこれ
名古屋名物のなんかスパゲッティソースの
袋
ジッパー付きです使いやすいサクリの
あずきアイスどういう状況本体クリップ
しまじろうメス最初の方やってた
チェーンソーマンのラバーストラップマ
さん当てましたありがとうございますはい
夜間こじらハム太郎マグカップに入ってる
と五等分の花嫁ミク
でこれ焚き火のフィギュアが入ってるん
ですけども
木の棒めっちゃ入ってるんですよこれ
にゃんこ大戦争ネコ番長ロックマンの
アクリルスタンドなんか可愛い生き物の
ラバーストラップウインナーショー猫
ちゃんと滑り台鍋すごい
可愛いクロミちゃんですね
チュッパチャパスのポーチ可愛いサスケの
ステージの最初のやつ
ぴょんぴょんって行くやつ
ムシキングの台ですおいしそうなパフェ
なんかお菓子の箱後ろのポーチ
ちょっと休憩しますね
はいというわけでガチャガチャ当たったの
こうやって見せるのちょっとあのすごい
あの
疲れた疲れたのでこっちにこうやって移し
ますこっちの方が見やすいと思うのでまた
地獄のようにあるので開けていきたいと
思います
可愛いパンに挟まれた猫ちゃん
可愛い
忍者カービー何これ猫の日給のクッキー
みたいな餃子何でもありだなもう
美味しそう
かアイスめっちゃ乗ってます
やばいマジでこれ
終わらないちょっとペースめっちゃ上げて
きますちっちゃい煎餅
組み立て式の車
うまい棒彼女をお借りしますすみちゃん
スパイファミリーのこれなんか中に水溜め
てこうやって飾るみたいです
可愛い
すごいなんか
釣りのあれだ釣りのあれルアーとか入れる
やつだこれ多分
壊れた
なアクリルスタンド
可愛い何これあハリーポッターだこれ
可愛いスネイプ先生
可愛いですね
首が動くのよこれほら
座ってないあスイカはスイカのこれ
シーサーですね
可愛いおおコキンちゃん車かなこれ車
カート見せてね
放射暴走セットですね
可愛い何これあっ広がった文化祭の時の
ドラムかっちゃんかっちゃんオタク大歓迎
ですよ楕円形明けますほっ何これ絶対仮面
ライダーだこれ仮面ライダーエボル
ちょっと俺の知らない仮面ライダーほいえ
可愛いえこれめっちゃいいななんか
ちっちゃい猫ちゃんですどうやって使うん
だろうこれあマグネットなのね本当だボー
ちゃんひっつきましたね次はワンピースと
たまごっちのコラボですけどマジで知らん
なんかつまなんか
詰まってるぞ詰まってるぞなんだこれ
なんか
詰まってるぞすごい詰まってるぞこれ何だ
わんわんだよワンワンのスーパーハイ
ブランド
ブレスレットですねこれ最高だ
馬鹿おしゃれこれあれじゃん
ローゼンメイデンだローゼンメイデンと
いうなんかすごいロリータのアニメが昔
だったんですけどもそのキャラクターです
ねなんで目にティッシュついてるんだろう
ハンターハンターだハンターハンターの
シャルナーク君ですねこのレパートリー
だったらな
クロロとか欲しかったですねマジでかっこ
いいはいなにこれセサミ
何これドラッグストアマスコットっていう
こういう商品だなのやつあるんですけど俺
この一番最後の
商品セットだけ当てちゃいましたね
島唄がないめっちゃちっちゃいハンド
ソープとかしかないんですよこれマジ
おいあーこれよく見るあれだ山餅っていう
こういうアイスあるよねボタンですね何
だろう音出る系かな
[音楽]
すごいねほんといろんなの思いつくねえ
からガチャすごいよもう何これカエルの
まんじゅう可愛い
クロワッサンになってるサメですねこう
いうの可愛いって思う
素敵ラブライブだラブライブのすみれちゃ
んってキャラクターです
モンスターズインクのサリー
可愛いクオリティめっちゃ高い
見たことないんだけどね何これ東京ドーム
のミニチュアモデル東京ドーム入ってます
ね開けるとお腹が東京ドームになってる
めっちゃパズあるんだけどもう無理本当は
これなんかウルトラマン入ってるはずなの
にこの飛行機の方当てちゃった感じかな
そうだね多分
[音楽]
なにこれなんか野球
盤のガチャガチャだったっぽいですね4番
が出てますこの機械のこと俺知らないけど
多分クオリティ高いんだろうなうんパック
マンチークの8割でその結構でかいですね
消しゴムなのこれ
可愛い欲しい
可愛いなスパイファミリーの不要な
フロストスパイの人ですねそうかっちゃん
がケーキになってますねなんかすごい爆
豪華次
ジョジョのスタンドみたいなやつでしょ
ちょっと詳しくないですけど
やばいやばいやばい
めっちゃ複雑そうえこれすぐ作れるんだよ
ねなんかええアバカここに溜まったか入れ
てこうやってねスティックで移動させ
玉を動かしてゴールに行かせるゲームだと
思います
寝てるリヴァイ兵長です
可愛い次これは何だ東京リベンジャーズな
のちょっと絵柄が違いすぎて分かんなかっ
たら灰谷くんのなんかアクリルキー
ホルダーですなるほど東京リベンジャーズ
こういうあれね売り方ねなるほどなるほど
可愛らしい
何これすごいなんかぷにぷにした
抹茶の鳥みたいなのが入ってます可愛いな
こんなのもガチャガチャになるんですね
体育
座りしてるカブが出てきましたどういう
こと
待ちぼうけっていうなんかそういう待っ
てる野菜みたいな傘がどういうのすごいな
何でもあるなもう次はでかいどういうこと
ただの怠け者って書いてあります
物入れそう
これは熱いドラゴンボールの
ウィンドウアートコレクションだうわー
これ集めてるドラゴンボールの歴代のこう
いう人気のイラストをねなんか額縁に入っ
てるっていうやつなんですけどもどれだと
思いますかクオリティ
めっちゃ高いいいなぁ亀仙人がかかった
何何何なんかすごいの入ってるけど
スライムか何これどういうこと手作り
ぷるぷる石鹸作れるんだってうわぁ
めっちゃ買うてあるな
[音楽]
おいすごいなんかセミが乗ってます
みたいなやつ
鳴いてくれるの
クオリティが高い
パンケーキと一緒に座ってるお犬さん
マイクラだエンダーチェストかなマイクラ
のいろんなポーチですねスヌーピーのお
化け可愛い何これ何これ
ラーメンとメロディーピチピチピッチ
アクアピッチアクセサリー計算
アクセサリーケースかなるほど
可愛い使います
これは俺わかるよ
プリキュアの衣装だうわ
センスいいなこういうのかわいいわ
プリキュアの多分
衣装だと思いますこの中のシャイニールミ
ナってやつが当たったんだと思います
可愛いしクオリティが高かったね
マインクラフトのクリーパー
可愛いミッフィーの仲間ですね寝てます
料理を
怖い
打てるキリンが入ってましたなぜ寝てる
とこでかいの開けます何これやばい結構
でかいできましたなんかトカゲみたいなの
できたでけえしめっちゃ透明だし
綺麗だけど
綺麗
だけどキャッシュディスペンサーいらん寝
てるくまさんのキーホルダー
[音楽]
可愛い最高に可愛い
スヌーピーと黄色い鳥
うわーこれなんだなんだっけなんとかなん
とかドラゴンみたいな爬虫類の何かペン
ケースかなこれすごいでかいな
腕時計
腕時計とかもあるの今うわマジじゃんマジ
でちゃんと機能してます
キュアホワイトアイスって何これすごい色
ですけどカプセルはいなるほどね地元で
売ってるようなアイスのガチャガチャです
ね見たことあるけど食べたことないですね
冷凍みかんでした
マニアハリーポッターホグワーツ魔法魔術
学校ピンズコレクションあめっちゃかっこ
いい
量のピンズコレクションみたいなやつ私
当たったのがスリザリンでしたかっこいい
これ普通にコンプリートしたくなるタイプ
ですね
めっちゃクオリティ高い変わった形の
カプセルを開けますミッフィーの友達は
可愛い
めっちゃ可愛いじゃんなんかスケルトンな
ドキンちゃん入ってましたセサミ
ストリートビッグバン
可愛い
溶けてるシナモロール開ける前から中身
わかるわこれエブリィ車のハスラーです
作るのめんどいんでここまでにさせて
いただきますシンプルな青いカプセル中に
はおお水星の魔女ソフィープロネさん
スレッドマーキュリーとかならわかるん
ですけどちょっとご存知ないですねせい
せいパンダ最近のガチャガチャはもう
カプセルから頼む済ませる系が多い気がし
ますねあのシンプルにパンダが1匹
[音楽]
可愛いパンダが寝てましたクオリティ高い
ね
金庫ですねはい開きませんが指の指紋
みたいなの付いてたのでこれをさして
ガチャってすると
[音楽]
開かない
ですねブリーチのフォトフレームです
めちゃくちゃちっちゃいサイズ感すごい
ガチャガチャもあった何これ赤い糸か運命
なのかほっ何えっ可愛いあーなるほどね
この
完成した猫にこうやって
毛玉で遊んでますみたいなやつ考えたね
ラバーマスコットすごいなピュレグミの
指輪
めっちゃリアル
可愛い太った鳥とおみくじが入ってました
なんやん中吉でしたなんかえげつないの来
たなこれスパゲッティっぽいのにイチゴと
キウイが乗ってるぞすげえクオリティは
マジで食品サンプルだなおこれ可愛い
クリームソーダのキーホルダー
何これこれこれいるかなガンダムの
プラモデルに塗るカラー剤みたいなやつ
ですそれのミニチュアですなかなか
マニアックなの作ったねミルキーのキー
ホルダー可愛いでか
ムーミンのお母さんポットアイスバーこれ
は俺の好きなシリーズですね一時期買い
まくってました動物サウナという動物の
サウナのシリーズがあるんですけどそれの
ワニ当たりましたかわいいピンクの鳥
うわぁ多分これなんですよこれ
無理もしもボックス
可愛いドラえもんのひみつ道具ですね
クオリティめちゃくちゃ高いなすごいよね
書いてあるんですけど寝転び今こんなに
なってんの人でもないじゃん大丈夫これ
ミスタードーナツエンジェルフレンチの
指輪かわいいです
[音楽]
消臭スプレーのキーホルダーチロルチョコ
マグネット
[音楽]
可愛いこれ
中に誰かいると思いますか誰だ中にね
マイメロちゃんが入ってます光る
ポチャッコ
可愛い猫ちゃんのポーチハニワストラップ
塗装してあげて
幽遊白書秘境お姉様やばいプーさんつねの
お面何これ何これ
粘土
[音楽]
粘土入ってんの
粘土入ってますね
[音楽]
コンクリートぽいからなんかこういうので
ジオラマを作ったりしてフィギュアが置け
たりするらしいですコンクリートに溺れて
しまったプーさんこのコンクリートいいな
なんか色んな使い道がありそうですね
鋼の錬金術師ヒューズ
すごいな何でも考えるなぁお刺身が
盛り合わせのスーパーで売ってるやつ
です食べれないよね俺もなんか錯覚してき
たんだけどやば
納豆のタレと悲しいのこれマグネットです
磁石マジで食べれるかと思ったわ危ない
あーなるほどね
喫茶店側にあるグラスねキラキラ光るキー
ホルダーはですすごいクオリティ高い
体入ってた買ってるとくっつけようという
ことがねねちゃんのうさぎさんだでも絆創
膏リングなにこれ
絆創膏の上からするリングみたいなやつ
入らん
初めてのりんちゃん
厳重なのが来ましたこれはうわでも
カプセルも
綺麗だな
ハンギョドン何してるのこんなところで
おっポケモンゴンベ可愛い猫の手押し車
ですやばこんなにハイクオリティなの今
マジで動くぞこれ
をエンではいいね
野良猫軍団とは
野良猫ではないぞタキシードサブ君の指輪
かわいい
人って入らんメロンパンナちゃんの人形
ティン
プリキュアの赤ちゃんこういうのでもよく
見るねポリンキー車のカーエンブレム
チームメイクトースター
クロワッサン入りです
[音楽]
文学小説が書いてあるエコバックです
結構しっかりしてるな逆にそう巻かれてる
とさ見たくなっちゃうじゃん何これ
[音楽]
何もない
何でもすごい見てバス
停まりますねこれすごいね
[音楽]
すごい
もう少しですさすがにね疲れてきましたよ
嘘だろ
プリンタリウム工作キット
なんかヤギにパーツ多いなと思ったんです
よすごいパーツがあってでまずこれ全部
しっかり
組み立ててその上でなんか穴開けないと
いけないんですよこの中にライト入れて
テラスと部屋中がプラネタリウムにな
るっていうとっても素敵
ラーメン屋さんのペンケース
仏像が入ってました感応菩薩マジで何でも
あり韓国の食べ物のポーチ
人型の魚
ジムニーナミスは
[音楽]
狂気を感じるなにこれなんかすごいぞこれ
すごい
宝箱
すごい光ってる中身が
可愛い
[音楽]
武器
10出てきたよこれ
辛ラーメンミンティア水の魔法使いモナ
たこ焼きイケメン麻雀のパイになんか足が
ついてます
潔い
キーホルダーポーチガクブルマイメロ
ハムスターヒヨコいやマジで何これ
トーマスのタッチパンダ
[音楽]
トラックザットクジラあれさっきなんか見
たことあるぞ
SNS名言チーズチーズバケット号
ソファー
焼き鳥家新しい
可愛い牛タン弁当ポーツ野菜飼育セット
クランキーの
ポーチーズキーホルダーアイスクリーム
120のティッシュ系食べ物よし
ひとまずある程度紹介は終わりましたまだ
全然ありますもうちょっとあります途中
からガシャポンじゃなくてカプセルじゃ
なくてボードで出てきたやつあるのでこれ
見ていきましょうおジャ魔女どれみ
可愛いプリキュアのシール名探偵コナンの
いい組み合わせマイメロとクロミちゃん
次の下敷き推薦でまずクリアビジュアル
ポスター地獄らくワンピースのうちは
可愛い
星の写真に挟む用のクリアファイル5等分
の花嫁は全員乗ってるやつでした
エヴァンゲリオン
マリマリマリここからは高いゾーンです
プレミアムガシャっていう最後1回
1000円とか1500円のやつあったと
思うんですけどあれも開けていきたいと
思いますもう見えてたと思うんですけど
スパイファミリーのやつからはボンドでし
た戦争のやつも見えてたと思うんですけど
落ちたでした
可愛いすみっコぐらしやっぱクオリティが
高いですね
プレミアムガチャ3つ残ってるんです
けれどもほぼ開けました全ての
ガシャガシャただ開けてる時に実は
クオリティの高いこれすごいなって思った
やつだけ実は取っておいたのでこの
プレミアムガチャも外やばいのでちょっと
これと一緒に紹介したいと思います
激ヤバクオリティガチャ紹介していきたい
と思いますまずはこちら見たことある人も
いるんじゃないでしょうかデッドバイデイ
ライトの発電機と
処刑台ですクオリティーやばいのよもう
完全に天気
処刑台もすごいこれちょっとねレベル違う
なって思いましたね
これからするとたまらないでしょうそして
次
閲覧注意です
[音楽]
でかすぎだろこれマジで怖いこれカエル
苦手なと思う泣いちゃうよぐらいの大きさ
ですね発電機に乗せておきましょうこれは
ね作るのが難しかったですはい
フェニックス不死鳥ですね多分ねこれ体の
可動域めちゃくちゃ広いんですよ
背中とかも全部動くし尻尾も1発ずつ
ちゃんと動くようになってて
首も可動すると
羽も広げられるかっこいいかどうか別とし
て作るのがすごく
難しかったですねこれはあのー二度と作り
たくないです次はこちらトリケラト間違え
たこちら
[音楽]
巨大なアリです
プリコネがすごいよどんだけディール
細かいんだよもう本当に巨大な蟻にしか
見えなくてこれはびっくりしましたね最近
のガシャのクオリティの高さが伺いました
[音楽]
怖い次はこちら
ゲーミングチェア
やばくないそれも稼働するんですよ椅子と
かここほらこうやって腕置くところも動く
し下も回転するともうマジで普通のね
ゲーミングチェアなのよ
ちゃんと
いやーこれは驚きましたねさすがにこれ
ハイクオリティ認定ですね
素晴らしい次はこちら
カマキ全部の体の部位動きます
腕とかも動くし足も全部動く作るのが
めちゃくちゃ難しかったですね超時間
かかりました
[音楽]
次はこちら
テント
ガチャでテントが手に入るんですよこれ
ちょっと中に物とか入るしもうマジで
テントそのものなんですよミニチュアの
テントが売られてましたクオリティが高い
何に使うのでしょうかはいガチャガチャで
ガチャガチャが出てきたんですよこれマジ
で回せるのよ中に本当に入ってるんですよ
ちょっと回してみますねこれ出てきたら
すごくない
[音楽]
できた出てくるんですこれ
ガチャガチャを作ろうという発想がやばい
ですね危険な思想の方ですこれはもう驚き
ましたさすがでございますそして次にこれ
はもうね何してくれてんだって感じでした
ビンゴマシーンこの周りのこれがカプセル
になってて
組み立てたらビンゴになるっていう中の
ビンゴの数字も全部入ってましたこれで
転がしたらビンゴできるのよ
はいこれがちょっとね個人的にクオリティ
高いなって思ったものでしたというわけで
プレミアムガチャ3つ残ってるのでこれも
あげたいと思いますこれ開けます
てんとう虫のやつだすごいクオリティが
高いてんとう虫の空飛んでる感じの完璧に
再現できてますねこれすごいのが勝ってる
改造してこういうスタンドになるんですよ
カプセルが土台になってこういう感じに
飾ることができますこれさすがですね
すごいさあと2つもう1個もね多分同じ
感じなんだと思うこれは
あったです
殿様だったかないやもうリアルすぎて
やばいマジでやばい
何で作ったんでしょう羽とかもついてるん
ですけどもちょっとあのやめときます
ラスト俺これが楽しみだった開けさせて
いただきましょう来ました
虹色クワガタです
開いちゃうんですねーすごいここも開い
ちゃうんだうわ
あいやちょっとさんのなんかてんとう虫と
かバットとかはあんまり好きじゃないん
ですけどハムとかが大好きなのでこの光り
方はまさに
プレミアムですね最高ですありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
はいというわけで全ての開封が終わりまし
た
[音楽]
あといや多いのは分かってたんですよ自分
で回しましたからただカプセルの中には
こんな大きくなるものもあったりとか
カプセル自体が頭になったりとかもうね
本当はあの手この手でいろんな
ガチャガチャ出てるなって思いましたもう
びっくりこれが今のガシャポンかすごい
ですねもうかなり多いし
300円400円500円とか結構多かっ
たのよ逆に今ね100円とか200円の
ガシャポンレアですもうなんか相場
400円ぐらいな気がしててかなり
クオリティが高かったんですけれどもさあ
気になるお値段の方総額発表していきたい
と思います300台近く回しましたこの
全ての金額
合計
17,300円
10万超えました10万7300円です
1000万以上の100円だもん入れまし
た全部回さないで今のガシャポンはどんな
もんなのかわからなかったので僕全然あの
いい経験できたなと思いますがですが全部
回しただけでこの中には俺がもう全くいら
ないっていうもの興味ないものあいいなっ
て思うものもうたくさんあります
ほぼ全社です申し訳ないですけどもねあの
僕もね物の好き嫌いありますよ好きなもの
嫌いなものこの中でもはっきり言い
ましょう全く入れないものもありますよ
なんで今からこの300個近くの
ガシャポンの景品から選び抜いて僕の
トップ5これはマジで良かったこれは
すごく良かったっていうのを発表していき
たいと思いますちょっと考えさせて
くださいね真剣に選ぶよ
はいというわけでトップ5決まりました
発表していきましょう第5位
[音楽]
こちらドラゴンボールのイラストのこの
なんか
額縁に飾ってるやつこれですその
亀仙人だったのであれなんですけども
亀井線に以外のやつも欲しいなって純粋に
思いましたドラゴンボール好きなので
ちょっとこれはね暑かったですね第5位と
させていただきます第4位
[音楽]
これです
宝箱
宝箱非常にディティールが細かい宝箱
ゲーム好きからするとねたまらない逸品
です
めっちゃクオリティが高いそして中開けて
光ってるのもねすごい可愛いんですよ
なんかお部屋のどこかにパッて置いとき
たいようなビジがめちゃくちゃいいなって
いうなんかアンティーク的に可愛いなと
思いましたこれ第4位です第3位動物
サウナ第3位は動物サウナですもうこれは
ね僕好きなシリーズなのでも集めてるのも
ありますサウナ大好きです動物がねサウナ
入ってるのこれたくさん集めて並べてみ
めっちゃ可愛いのよこれはもうほんと個人
的に欲しかったなっていうフィこれ第3位
とさせていただきますおめでとうござい
ます第2位これはちょっと
意外かもしれませんがこの
椅子家具ですねこの
椅子2位です
これやばくないクオリティガチャガチャで
出てきちゃいけないクオリティなのよこう
いう家具はミニチュアの家具結構もともと
好きでコロナ流行ってた時とかミニチュア
でなんか
街作ろうとしてたぐらいなんかミニチュア
の物が好きなんですけどもう超えてさ
ソファに乗せるだけで可愛いじゃん
いろんな使い方できると思うんですけれど
もかなり
精巧に
作らソファーガシャポンで手に入ったのが
すごいなと思ってこれ僕第2位とさせて
いただきましたそして第1位皆さん何だと
思いますかこの中で僕が一番良かったって
思うやつ1個あります紹介してますどれだ
と思いますでしょうかでは発表させて
いただきます
第1位
[音楽]
こちらトゲトゲ新しい
意味わかんないでしょ僕結局意味わかん
ないから一番好きなんですよなぜアザラシ
をこんなことにしたのだろうか全部1回
ずつガシャ回したんですけども1回だと
全部揃わないんですよこれはちょっと俺
コンプしたいなと思って実は撮影終わった
後にコンプするまで回してみましたその
映像をご覧くださいどうぞこれはこれが
一番気に入りましたアザラシ物体見てこれ
はねアザラシの物体です
これだけコンプします
ほい俺やるよ
5種類あるんでまずはあれだねピラミッド
型だね
マジでわからん
これ写せる
[音楽]
ぞ来てる来てる来てるひねりが加えられた
アザラシ今のところかぶってないぞほら
すごい
ドロッとしたやつ
ここでかぶらなかったらでかいよ
真ん中のドロドロだけ
ノーミス言ったらすごくないすごいはい
やばい始まった始まった
そういう遊び方もできるんです
重さでわかるよねだいたい
やばいことになってきたこれ
かわいいピラミッド
やばいやばいやばい
全部一応2種類ずつ出てましたドロドロ
レアまであります
やばい20分で来ちゃうけどこれ大丈夫
おいやばいぞマジで
コンプってこんなむずになる
軽い軽い軽い
軽いということは絶対あれじゃ
んそんな気がしたそんな気がしたのよ
軽いってことはね
このやばいぞどうするこれマジでこれを
出せばいいだけでしょ
簡単に簡単
これ多分トゲトゲだね
マジでわかる
うわぁ
大人だな
どうしよう
どうしよう了解してくるね両替してきまし
たマジで終わらせますもうやばい笑えない
ある俺が欲しいやつかピラミッドから
どっちかです
これが
伝説のこれが伝説のこの確率見てください
脅威です
[音楽]
これマジでトップレアを全く当たりません
ので是非皆さんも買ってみてください
以上現場からでしたはいというわけで
コンプしましたがすごい量になってしまい
ましたはいというわけですごい量の
ガチャポン回してみたんですけれども回す
のも大変だし開けるのも大変だし最近のは
こりすぎてて組み立ても大変もうマジでね
あの2日間かかりました真剣に
ちょっと大きい場所があったら教えて
ください行ってみたいと思います
[音楽]